Cómo llega a Brasil a estas elecciones
está la sociedad más dividida que en las
anteriores
Hola Muchas gracias por la invitación
Pues sí aquí el clima está de mucha
polarización vemos a la gente muy
emocionada con esa selección es una
elección donde hay también un nivel de
violencia política muy grande entonces
la gente está muy preocupada en salir
con prendas con
del color de su
candidato Pero bueno se ve que la
emoción está en todos entras en un bar
en una escuela en una panadería y toda
la gente está hablando de la elección
presidencial y han hecho los candidatos
llamados a la calma para la jornada de
votación o por el contrario han avivado
la división con sus discursos
Eso depende hay un candidato el
expresidente Lula que está como haciendo
un intento y diciendo no Vamos a darnos
las manos pero el presidente Box sonaro
es muy conflictivo tuvimos un debate el
pasado jueves donde estaba ha estado ahí
hablando como un poco
colocando sus electores leales votantes
leales para la pelea y hablando de
bolsonaro hay dudas sobre si aceptará la
derrota o no que podría pasar si
cualquiera de los dos principales
candidatos no reconoce la victoria rival
sí que hay dudas pero Hoy tuvimos un
momento muy importante del tribunal
superior donde se fue a la televisión
donde hizo un test de integridad de la
de la urna electrónica donde estuvimos
un paso a paso muy importante de decir
bueno eso funciona de esa manera
Entonces está tranquilo
y bueno ese bolsonaro hizo a largo de
los 40 días de campaña
diversas
momentaciones a decir de que quizás no
va a aceptar a
el resultado de la
de la elección pero las instituciones
sus ministros dicen que toda la tarde a
ver a ver qué pasa
y las últimas encuestas daban a Lula en
torno a un 48% del voto es posible que
el candidato de izquierda gane en
primera vuelta
justo Salieron dos encuestas ahora hace
cinco minutos y que está por encima de
los 50 por ciento nuestra regla dice que
necesita 50% más uno y creo que es
matemáticamente posible
esto Esto es el porcentaje que llega le
deja muy dependiente de dos grupos los
de que todavía no se han decidido y los
importantes
pero todavía a esperar lo que van a
hacer en en la urna no